if you were to instruct someone to do
the worst possible things in the morning
to set their day up for failure what
would they be
uh wake up and stay in bed uh well wait
there are good reasons to stay in bed in
the morning but once those are completed
then
staying in bed
is curtin's throne yeah curtains drawn
just using your passively scrolling on
social media um
like they're
there are neurobiological data showing
that when you are upright you actually
are stimulating this area of the brain
called locus ceruleous whereas when you
recline you actually are less alert
literally the position of your body
dictates some of your levels of
alertness that's why you suggest uh
people to not sit like this
at their work desk right yes and if
you're look and
if you're looking down
while working you're actually less alert
than you could be if your eyes are
averted slightly over most people that
are on their phone including me and the
postural stuff is really bad too i mean
i'm getting i'm trying to really combat
that internal rotation you know that the
c-shaped human kind of thing you know um
it's really not good i'm really trying
in fact one this is so common now the
c-shaped human thing that um it almost
feels strange to be upright you know
like people like exactly the open uh the
the uh
sort of external rotation is good for us
we know this but in bed i would say in
bed so people are on their phone they're
in bed they're not getting enough light
or they just artificial light or they're
trying to get the sunlight through the
window terrible um
they are then going and sitting and
getting into like hip you know hip
flexor contraction
um
they're drinking coffee too early in the
day
uh
they aren't getting into any kind of
movement but it's mostly about
the sort of randomization of activities
they're sort of making a cup of coffee
while texting um not getting sunlight
you know then they're scattering that in
with like a little bit of work but then
something hits that's stressful and
they're diverting their attention
they're sort of building in this eight
attention deficit like disorder
through these they're doing they're not
single tasking they're not monotone and
they're not being deliberate or
intentional with the things that they're
doing they're just allowing the morning
to kind of come and take them wherever
the wind blows that's right and i have
to say even though i describe my routine
accurate my morning routine accurately
if i were to really optimize it and i've
done this from time to time i would get
up
i would hydrate and i would immediately
exercise
i would use that early you know peaking
of the cortisol response that comes with
waking to get the body into action sort
of jocko willing style right 4 30. i
always see his posts but i see them at 7
00 am yeah yeah yeah precisely
so
you know so chuckles up performing again
today yeah yeah oh he seems to always uh
beat me by a few minutes unless i wake
up in the middle of the night for a
moment but
to really get into action because that's
going to generate its own
dopamine and adrenaline response anytime
i've worked out really early like if i
have a flight and then
you know and then moved into the other
components of my day
i find that i feel better all day long i
i also will say if i work out really
early maybe between seven and eight a.m
well then my first meal might land at
nine a.m so
you know you need to be flexible with
some of these things but the general
principles
apply i notice that you haven't put cold
exposure on your morning routine i'm
going to guess you must have a cold tub
of some kind of you have a cold tub and
a sauna i've been less good about that
lately the best time to do that for me
is on my cardio days i do it after
because you don't want to do it post
hypertrophy because you're going to
blunt some of the responses that are
actually you're trying to get by the the
workout itself that's right and i have
one i should say i have one rest day per
week where i don't do any cardio or
weight training i really like doing
having a complete rest day but on that
complete rest day
if i can i'll do
20 minutes of sauna and then cold for
three minutes 20 minutes of sauna and
then cold i'll make the rest day
reparative and generally we make that
social where we're talking about things
and and we're very social in our working
out like we we talk uh my partner and i
talk while we work out i you know when
it's set when it's time to do a set i
become a little bit of like the drill
sergeant like let's do your set do your
set but then occasionally i'm the guy
doing a set and i'm like all right so
this afternoon we're gonna you know
but i try and i try and really focus and
i enjoy training by myself too but
generally we train together and then
and then typically if we're doing ice
bath or something we try and coordinate
those things what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace